everybody filters in um don't worry
there's just a you can take your seats
just a few slides where we
introduce myself from the talk my name's
ian cooper you can find me on twitter as
i cooper
uh my dms are open and i'm usually happy
to engage a little bit about anything
i'm talking about
um today's talk what is going to be
about um if we have a synchronous api so
you can think of those as events or
messages
how do we go about owning and managing
them i do quite a few talks about
you know how we build event driven
architectures and how we design them and
this one's more about well you've got
one
how do you look after it how do you do
all those things that
kind of like fall into the the line of
admin for your api
so i am it says that i'm old i only ever
really draw attention to the bottom
point i got my start in speaking because
i still do around a user group and when
we started there was nobody else to talk
apart from us
um that's just led me up here doesn't
mean i'm particularly
any kind of genius uh any of us really
can do this and i do encourage you to
have a stab but it's great and all of
you will know something
that someone else doesn't know and very
easy i find to think but i don't know
anything and it's like actually but if
you you do know some things you just
don't realize you know them and there'll
be a junior dev somewhere that wants to
know what you know right
uh and i work on an open source project
called brighter we do it's a messaging
framework for
net developers we have a python version
called brightside
all right we can talk about we're going
to talk about the notion of endpoints
what are they why are they important to
us and we get a little bit into bits of
domain driven design a little bit of the
ideas of contracts
then we'll talk about the notion of
having decided what endpoints are in the
world of asynchronous kind of
conversations we'll talk a little bit
about
um discovery of those endpoints
and then we'll get into describing them
at the end points and particularly the
contracts they hold
uh and then we'll get a little bit into
some of the things interesting things we
can do once we have those like using it
for infrastructure as code
and explore some of the ideas we've been
playing with
one of the things that i like to make
sure we are all agreed on first of all
though is what do we mean
by an asynchronous api right what's a
synchronous conversation and it seemed
for extinctless conversation both
parties must be present for
communication to succeed
right you both have to be there at the
same time and the canonical example is
of course a phone call
right iphone you up if you're not there
there is no communication
right
now nowadays the only person that phones
me is my mum
my mom is in her 80s so that i think
that's fair and she likes to hear my
voice occasionally
everybody else just uses whatsapp or
messenger or signal or whatever whatever
mechanism we have agreed to send
messages over and the reason people do
that
is because it's easier
typical protocols here for synchronous
open api graphql grpc thrift and soap
so asynchronous conversation is the
other kind that khan we're really used
to using
in an asynchronous conversation the
receiver does not need to be present at
the same time as the sender communicates
with them using store and 4 to pick up
the message later
chronicle example would be snail mail in
a letterbox right i send you a letter
if you're american it goes and lives in
one of these nice mailboxes of the flag
if your british just pops through our
door
um what it means is
you can get to the mail whenever right
whenever you're ready when you come home
at the end of the day there's the mail
waiting for you didn't need to be
present when i sent it
so i decouple
sender and receiver in terms of in in
time they don't need to both be
available at the same time which
generally increases the valuability of
our platform it is much easier to build
a platform where i don't have to have
you both available at the same time
right some probability theory that you
probably did on maths years ago
explains she is much easier to get up
time where you don't have to both be
simultaneously available
um
and the real question is how do we
describe these kinds of things so what's
up effect etcetera are those kind of
things you use today they're all
asynchronous
conversations and protocols today like
rabbitmq kafka sns they're all
asynchronous right
okay let's talk about endpoints
so uh back in the day there was a a
toolkit called i think it's an open
source version now called windows
communication foundation
um built by some smart people outdated
nowadays it's very based around
principles like soap but it had a quite
nice definition of what an end point was
and really based on that endpoints are
places where messages sent or received
and they define the information required
for the message exchange so just a
conceptual idea right but we have an app
and our app wants to basically send
messages or receive messages and what we
do that through is an end point and it
isn't necessarily just for messaging
right even for something synchronous so
you know we can think about an http
endpoint somewhere where we send and
receive http or we can think about you
know a messaging endpoint for kafka it's
somewhere where we send and receive
kafka right
in order for an endpoint to be useful to
us
we have to think about where messages
should be sent how they should be sent
and what they should look like
and what wcf used to call these the abcs
address binding and contract which is
kind of easy to remember so i quite like
that uh little model of how these things
work
all right
so so what are these things in terms of
um uh what the messages should look like
right we'll worry about basically where
they should where and how they should be
sent in a second
but what are these things in terms of
what they should look like
what are we sending
okay
let's do a little bit of ddd theory
so i have
a business usually that i am working for
in terms of delivering software
and the business does some stuff and we
talk about that being the domain right
so i currently work just to take away
our domain is the domain of what the
technical quick commerce getting you
your food before it gets cold right and
now people are extending into getting
your groceries before effectively you i
don't know get thirsty
and within that domain we may define a
number of sub domains so the remains big
and hard to think about and much we
don't want to build huge monoliths
anymore all right to deal with the whole
thing so it's put up in smaller parts
like how do we onboard a restaurant
how do we determine if a restaurant is
currently available
to offer food
and typically what we would then do is
say
okay we need to basically create a model
of that sub domain
so bounded context in ddt just a model
of our
our our domains our subdomains in this
case
we could model any given sub domain in a
quite
large number of ways
a bounded context is just one model
right we've chosen to basically
represent it in
c sharp or java or all those things
would be equally valid models the
bounded context just says here is our
model right here is how we chose to
represent that
if we are lucky
there is a kind of one-to-one alignment
between sub-domains like hey we've got a
settlement about restaurant onboarding
we've got one about rational
availability and we have a context for
each of them
in more legacy systems you tend to find
that that alignment slips
right what happens is we begin to think
about our domain in new ways our
business may pivot or change we may not
want to really consider onboarding
restaurants to really be a domain we
deal with so much anymore and we may
find effectively we now have a new
sub-domain to think about and our old
bounded context form as part of that
that's why we do this exercise called
context matrix and ddd right but for the
minute let's just
assume we have a nice perfect world in
which
sub-domains and bounded contexts are
pretty much the same thing but just to
be aware they're not
right and the bounded context is the
code the schemas even the team
boundaries basically
that represent a given domain right so
you can think of it almost like a
business capability it's the people the
processes and the technology that go to
basically make up our representation of
a given sub domain
that's what the boundary context means
and within that bounded context we agree
the meaning of certain terms you'll
notice here that we have both a
restaurant and restaurant on boarding
and we have a restaurant and now what's
going to be called restaurant
availability and one on the other side
um
and we may not agree
in those two models what a restaurant
looks like
restaurant on boarding may care about
things like the address they make about
the phone number make about the name of
the manager effectively use on shift at
a given time but the restaurant
availability may just care about the
hours that the restaurant keeps how long
it takes basically to close down the
restaurant at the end of the evening so
that they won't do his service there
etc all right
so we're modeling quite different things
although they're both a restaurant we
call that a poly scene
as a name for a bound of context right
and so we've got this idea of different
representations of a domain concept
now
well we'll talk about apis rather than
ddd so how is that relevant
so in this model it's quite likely that
what happens is i on board a restaurant
and having onboarded a restaurant the
information about a new restaurant flows
to our restaurant availability service
where effectively someone can go in and
start entering things like shift hours
so our
restaurant availability service needs to
know about restaurants which have been
created by restaurant management
and typically if we're going to be
asynchronous in order to increase the
availability of our platform then it
means restaurant management is raising
some kind of event
saying here's a new restaurant or here's
an updated restaurant or you know
someone took that restaurant out of our
out of our platform
and the restaurant based availability
service has to listen to those messages
so what is the content of that message
where does it come from
well we have a relationship here between
restaurant management which effectively
seems to own
this this conversation it's the person
initiating the conversation
and restaurant availability who is
essentially receiving information
and we tend to think about them as being
upstream and downstream
the downstream the receiver
depends upon the upstream team if the
upstream team makes changes to its model
the downstream team would need to react
the reason we talk about downstream and
upstream
is
the analogy would be you think of two
cities one on a showing a river and one
is upstream and one is downstream if the
upstream city starts dumping all of its
waste completely untreated into the
river it may well be that the downstream
city is drinking that as it's drinking
water that's a problem for the
downstream city
so what we say is we should try and
manage this relationship
so that the restaurant management team
the upstream team
are not just basically
destroying the lives of the downstream
team
and so we say that they have a customer
and supplier relationship
that the upstream team is the supplier
the downstream team is the customer
and the upstream team should think about
looking after the needs of their
customers
otherwise we end up in this kind of
world
right conformance this is kind of like
we have a supplier
an upstream and a downstream but that
don't really care
and in this model what happens is the
restaurant team we're doing on the
onboarding
they say
we're going to take our internal data
structure that represents a restaurant
and we're just going to serialize that
out as the message
or if they've decided for some
benighted reason to do event sourcing oh
or all of our event sourcing events
we'll just basically expose them and
send them down the system hey we've got
internal domain events saying a
restaurant's been on board well we're
just that's what we'll send over kafka
to everybody else telling them there's a
new restaurant all right
and the problem with that is as soon as
that team says oh i've got interesting
refactoring here maybe we need to change
the restaurant identifier from being
this integer because we've got super
scale now and that identity number on
the sql server is no longer working for
us we're going to shift over to dynamo
and use a guide instead
they completely break the downstream
team who've been sitting there going
we've got lovely integers for our
restaurants and that's what we've been
collating all this time
right every time you make a change
a downstream team system breaks
because
their schemer is the schemer you have
internally
so the first rule is just don't do this
right
don't expose your internal domain model
on your events leaving your api because
when you want to change it you'll break
everyone upstream of you
well downstream is your other
okay
or
you can't change anything because you're
breaking people down stream maybe right
like i said you can't change that your
brake at all right
so what are our options well one option
is if the upstream team and not being
particularly helpful
for whatever reason they're not
particularly good team players
is that the downstream team or being
builds what they call an anti-corruption
layer so anti-corruption layer provides
an ad hoc translation service per
customer that translates the format used
by the supplier that answered by the
customer in other words i build
something that says when i get their
message i'll turn it into something i
can use internally consistently so it'll
always look like this and i don't have
to keep changing my code the only thing
i have to do when the upstream team
changes them their internal
representation is figure out it broke go
to my anti-corruption layer fix it and
then effectively it'll flow through my
system correctly
that's kind of our least worst option
the only slight problem with this is a
if there's a whole load of people
listening to restaurant onboarding so
certainly in my in you know in my
current field
lots of people want this restaurant data
right they want to basically know about
restaurants
they're all writing anti-corruption
layers
and the second thing is if the upstream
team don't tell you before they decide
to change their internal model and you
break everybody you still got to fix
everything even they've got one place to
fix it for each individual team right
if you're lucky they're telling you you
can go and fix your anti-corruption
layer that doesn't always work because
they don't necessarily know you exist
so that's kind of your least worst
option
the other option is what domain driven
design calls an open host service which
is just a fancy name for saying
get restaurant management to expose a
proper api
okay
so an open host sales reduces
duplication and many anti-corruption
layers by supporting shared models the
upstream team agrees to sport an
external model that might differ from
their internal one and implies an open
host model that supplier agrees to
support and customers depend upon what
does that mean so what happens it means
is restaurant management say okay we are
going to define
what we send and you can rely on that
it'll be like an api we'll publish it
somewhere and we'll say this is what a
restaurant looks like
it may not be how we represent it
internally in fact we may keep changing
how we represent it internally
but when we send something externally
this is the shape it will have if we
want to change that shape there's now a
process of negotiation between us and
all of the consumers
it may be that we ask you to be tolerant
readers
right so tolerant reader just means
effectively you'll accept things that
aren't necessarily exactly the shape you
predicted
but they don't harm you in any way so if
somebody adds new fields that you don't
understand you don't care you just
ignore those because they're not
somebody else and they're not for you
but you have the data that you want
right
you might agree early on with this team
that certain fields you you can have
sensible defaults for if they're missing
you'll have sensible default right it's
missing the lat long don't worry you'll
send them all to nil island right to
zero zero not ireland
so you might ask the dowshin team to be
a tolerant reader and that means
essentially it makes it slightly easier
to do some things add some new fields
that new customers need um effectively
drop some fields that most people aren't
actually using
uh in a kind of st as a phase process i
stopped producing data there you start
defaulting it until you can actually
drop it and get rid of it right we've
moved from doing lat long to three words
or something like that
but the key idea is you agree a contract
okay
you agree some kind of stable contract
that you'll give other people
and we talk about this as being
necessary coupling right here's the
thing right i could build up i could
build some software that was completely
decoupled if it sat like on my computer
in a basement attached to nothing and it
would be utterly useless to anybody
right
so what we have to do is accept that you
are going to have some kind of
dependency on things upstream on you
there's a certain amount of coupling
that happens a necessary coupling says
actually in order to do our job
we have to listen to this information
so it's necessary coupling because to
collaborate with us we must allow others
to take a dependency on us right so we
say okay we are going to accept
that this contract is a bit rigid
that it can't change too often
that we the upstream team although we
can make internal changes are limited as
to the shape the new shapes we can give
restaurant by the fact that we have
customers of it and we the downstream
team have to recognize that you know we
have to take a dependency on somebody
upstream
but we have to take work so this
contract becomes quite important right
and so that's why in a lot of cases when
we talk about apr is what we want to
surface to people is you should think
about how you design this
because it's going to be long lived
once it's out there and you have a
number of consumers of it
it's harder to change than some internal
code you can't refactor
your api quite as easily right imagine
you want to do the whole thing where
you've exposed a an id which is
effectively an integer because you just
picked up the identity field that was
being generated for you in sql server
you couldn't scale sql server anymore so
you moved to dynamo and you decided to
you needed a good etcetera presenter and
you wanted to put it on a string
right how would you do that well what
you have to initially do is give new id
alongside old id because you have people
depending on the old id format of using
integer you just put the integer as a
string in new id
and then you say to everybody please get
off your old id when everyone says to
you we're off old id you can
we're now reading the new id you can now
say great now i'm going to start
shipping new idea effectively as a good
when everyone accepts that you say okay
now we're going to retire older ids
there's only going to be new id that one
goes great then you say now we're going
to create id again but it's just going
to be a string it's going to be the same
as new id and everyone goes great and
then you can say now we can get rid of
new ideas right it's quite a lot of work
so you have to think
about these things as being quite
long-lived they need a little bit of
forethought planning and they probably
need a little bit of review typically
the best way to review them is to talk
to the people who are going to consume
it right and any subject experts you
have and say hey let's all have a look
at my api and figure out if we think we
can think what's wrong with it before we
actually put it out there right just
think about conscious being long lived
okay
uh habitable versus plant consumer yeah
so this is habitability something we can
all live with
all right
so
you've figured out that what you
actually need to do is
not expose your internals somebody else
have an api
except it's a long-term contract that
you can't change easily
um and you need to manage basically that
contract
okay how does anybody else find out
about it
so let's imagine effectively i am
restaurant availability and i decide
what i need is an upstream message from
somebody basically who on boards
restaurants
one question would be well where do i
find this contract typically
in a lot of organizations
i hop onto slack
and i post a message in some general
forum saying anyone know who produces
messages for new restaurants who has
this this is their favorite technique
a few of you here's the other technique
which basically is i go to github and i
search github for what i think the
message might be called and see which
team might produce anyone got that
a few more github searches than slack
people yeah i mean this is very typical
right
i i've got a contract it exists i've
defined one but nobody can find it
okay
the other problem is the inverse
if i have a message and i need to change
it
and to change that contract and then my
first steps were in negotiation with
everybody that consumes it
how do i find them right to find the
producer how do i know who consumes my
message
again typically someone posts a message
saying anyone using this my this message
can they get in touch with you want to
change it or i troll github saying i
wonder if anyone's actually got my
message schema
as part of their code base all right
it's not very effective
so we need to document our asynchronous
api somewhere right we need some
mechanism to document them we need to
document our endpoints effectively
um
it's our contract what do we need what
do we need to document well
we're going to need to document the
channel what's the channel so a channel
is when messaging terms really just an
abstract idea it's the virtual pipe that
that connects sender and receiver and we
already use it for a whole range of
concepts but it's really saying there is
something over which we can send
messages that is somehow addressable
so in kafka it's your topic right in
rabbit mq it's your routine key it's sns
it's a topic as well right
and that it says hey i want to send
messages to or from this thing
so we need to understand what the
channel is so you know where to find it
right
way to protocol
right if it's going to be kafka is it
going to be sns right ss is ready just
http with semantics right
is it going to be mqp
how are we sending this stuff what do
you need to do to listen to the
things that i'm sending
and then we need to say well i am the
sender
right i am this app
probably i might be useful to know who
the people are that own the app right
which team
are there any contact details um
do they have a repo somewhere and who
subscribes to it right but you know
they've got a documentation somewhere
saying hey this my app subscribes that
message
because that tells us
what's going on
so endpoints as you remember is the
definition we had earlier placement
message sent or received that they tell
us
where messages should be sent how they
should be sent and what they look like
right
so we've been discussing what should
they look like
we're saying basically there should be a
contract which is long-lived
and we're saying also
we're discussing how they should be sent
protocols like kafka or mqp and where
they should be sent so channels right
okay so document a contract for an
endpoint an endpoint for a message
should be sent how they should be blah
blah okay
so the message is the data that we send
or receive is our contract effectively
and it tends to have two things the
metadata
the headers that we send so generally uh
when we send something we need metadata
which really tells us how to process
the message that's in flight it doesn't
tell you what the data is that the
domain cares about but it says things to
you like what is the id of this
is there another message it correlates
with is it if it's a large message it's
been broken up into a number of pieces
is this basically do i expect to reply
if so do i tell you where to reply to me
etcetera so metadata about processing
the message
and then effectively the body
which tells us essentially what is the
actual content of the message we need to
document both usually
the channel right
where the message is going to flow the
address
and the binding and the binding says
there may well be information we need to
know as part of this protocol which
tells us how to send messages
uh to and from
this end point
okay it may tell us um how to basically
uh authenticate ourselves in order to
communicate with basically this endpoint
right
it may tell us um
[Music]
where the
uh
broker is that we need to connect to uh
in terms of it's basically address in
order to actually uh communicate over
this channel
so there's technical information that we
have to have alongside that um uh and it
may also have things like you know are
we a binary we plain text all that kind
of information
and in principle we can have multiple
binaries for the same channel so in
principle we might actually
say hey we talk about basically a new
restaurant being created and we make
that available for amqp and kafka and
this talk's not really about why we
might want to do that
but
be aware that's possible
all right
so let's say we want to describe
endpoints how might we do that
okay
so async api
is a emerging standard
for documenting our endpoints who here
has used open api
yeah quite a few of you so really async
api is just open api but for
asynchronous apis instead
okay and uh open api was a direct
inspiration used by the async api
developers initially although it's it's
moving on from that
so um uh it's looking at the bottom open
governance so async api has become part
of the linux foundation so essentially
it is it is owned and controlled by a
foundation effectively now so you have
some kind of like uh continuance it has
a community they're actually a very
welcoming community they have you can
get invited to their regular kind of
stand-up meetings about effectively
what's happening in their world or
looking at new version specification
they're currently working on three
there's a slack channel they are very
very welcoming it is early enough in the
lifespan of 18 kpi there's a small
enough uh community people coming
involved the um
you can get to know people in the
community quite easily
and what they produce is a specification
which is specification which says here's
how effectively you should document your
apis
and they also effectively produce
tooling
which essentially lets you
work with apis documented in that style
to produce new effects and we'll talk
about that a little bit more later on
towards the end part that in your head
that you can basically build tooling off
it but we'll come back to that later all
right
okay so generally what you do with async
api is you document an app what do you
mean by an app well we just mean you
know some
uh
process that effectively you intend to
run that has some kind of functionality
and generally your app
has a role and it may have more than one
role and it can act
as a producer as a consumer or both so
it's a producer it's sending messages if
it's a consumer it's consumed messages
often absolutely both right i receive
messages i do some work and i generate
new ones so i'm both a producer and a
consumer and we document what that
individual app produces and consumes
okay
we send messages over channels and they
are hosted on a server
um uh and maybe more than one channel so
the channel must be addressable in other
words we have to have to give the
channel a unique identifier of some sort
so i know effectively that you are
talking about this channel or post
another channel specification right if
i'm receiving one and sending two that
might be three channels right
so generally channels they've on a
server
um
it's a little bit of a historic thing
channels living on a server because
generally with pub sub we don't really
care so much about the server we we have
a notion really more of effectively of a
broker that we might care about um and
the server abstraction tends to think
more in terms of hey i am a thing
hosting an api whereas really in pub sub
land in messaging we think more of
hey here is a channel i can subscribe to
so three will fix that slightly um but
for now server what we tend to use it
for in most pub sub models is where is
the broker that i'm using
okay
there's a message effectively definition
you have to have a payload or a header
um async api is reasonably open to how
you choose to define
the contract that you're going to
basically produce in your api so by
default you can just use json schema to
say this is what my message looks like
but it also supports you choosing to use
things like avro those of you who don't
know what avro is it's a standard that
came out of the kafka community for
defining basically a schemer it has both
a binary and a plain text format
but you can also use effectively
protobuf so you can use any other kind
of major players in terms of basically
schema definition for things you're
sending
um
and a channel also basically has a
protocol by which matches your exchange
so kafka or sns etc and what happens is
you define a binding at multiple levels
inside async you'll see this more clean
a second async api to define how
essentially that protocol is applied to
either
channel definitions to how messages work
or effectively to how the server is
constructed we'll see that so
all right
so what does the document structure i
sync api look like so you have basically
an async api object is the root object
it says kind of document object model
all things live off that
all right below that we have an info
object which is meta specification this
is where you effectively say
my team built this this is how you get
in touch with us um uh we are the owners
effectively of this particular
specification all right and so if you
are a producer of a message they would
someone would then know you're the team
effectively that i need to talk to about
basically the stuff that's been produced
if you're a consumer
vice versa right
it has a service object which is
basically a connection just for the
server so essentially depending on the
role this may affect you this may be um
uh your app could actually be acting as
a server um in some of the models
and other models but once potential
messaging tends to be basically just the
address of the brokers that's where your
kafka broker is that's where your
private mq brokers etc you can have
multiple servers so you can effectively
say here is my production instance here
is my qa instance here is my local dev
instance and you can list them kind of
all so that effectively people can
figure out which one they should they
should be talking to
all right
a channels object which basically says
okay
what are we sending and what are we
sending over it
so overall the channel subject has a
name and says essentially the name of
this channel which is actually just
disambiguated from other channels and
maps well to say a topic on kafka for
example
beneath that is a channel item an
operation object which is a bit
complicated
operation objects essentially say am i
sending or am i receiving on this
channel and what am i sending or
receiving what is the message
there's also effectively an operation id
which kind of names the operation which
is mainly used for things like code
generation right
now
uh there's also a components object and
the components object lets you kind of
say actually rather than defining that
thing in line i'd like to put it in my
components section
and typically what that's used for is a
message definition right let's put my
message definition in here rather than
in lining it inside the actual
definition of the channel
okay
and tags so i can tag a given
specification in case that helps me
organize it and make it more searchable
et cetera
so
uh async object has an id means you need
to convert identifier basically the top
level that's all it really requires so
here i'm using an example from my open
source project saying here's a typical
song project we use i'm just going to
give it an id
here's an info object
um so again i'm just using one from my
source project you can see there's the
name of the project the url where you're
going to find us how you email us for
support
license which is probably a bit weird
internally right you just probably
ignore that
internally but a description of the app
which is very useful a title version
number of your your version of
specification right so all very useful
and some tags uh so we can help find it
right
service object all i'm doing here is
defining a local one but you could
obviously define production et cetera
i'm just telling you where to find the
broker that i'm going to use and in my
case here i'm going to use kafka and i'm
saying effectively
you can find the instance that we're
that i'm running my local one at
localhost 9092 right and obviously for a
production system you'd have the actual
production
url of your kafka cluster
this then is a channel
so you can see it's called for example
greeting here in the top corner ignore
the scribe for the second we'll come
back to that and then effectively just
imagine we're saying there's an
operation performing on that channel
here's a summary of the operation here's
a description of which is longer and
here's a message the message you know
says a hash ref we'll come back to that
saying but all it means is
go and look in this part in the
components section of this
definition rather than in line to find
what the message looks like it just
makes it clear cleaner all right
so we're saying
just in the summary
we send a greeting here and the
description says hey this is how we send
greeting to another service and we call
the operation send greeting so obviously
what we're defining is we send something
on a channel
notice we use the word subscribe that's
a bit weird right why is it subscribe
okay so this is anomaly that still
exists in 18 kpi 2 which will get fixed
and that is because originally when it
was built
uh it was built by people dealing with
things like web sockets the you could
the server was kind of a role your app
might be in
and if you were in the role of a server
you were exposing operations to people
and one of those operations was you can
subscribe to me because i send messages
right
and when they flip that over for a
consumer they're like well i guess the
consumer
you can publish to them and actually in
some ways that kind of works right if i
think about how sns and sqs work right i
i i do as sqs give you permission to
publish to my queue from sns right
but it's a bit weird for most of us so
i'll show you later but and with three
it gets fixed and they're just going to
use the term center and receive to mean
what we
would understand to mean but when you
come across this first first of all you
will do a little bit of double taking go
that doesn't make any sense just history
about where the spec came from early
versions
ref so ref just lets you basically say
hey this lives elsewhere um you can say
it lives in the same file by using a
page fragment indicator um to say
effectively go look in the component
section that's where my definition of
greetings lives more
usefully you can say it lives in another
file why is this useful because
typically with a message contract you'll
both want to have have it for the
producer saying i send this and for the
consumer saying this is what i read
now you can go to the effort of saying
actually producer and consumer are not
necessarily the same because the
consumer mates used to consume only a
fraction of that message they may only
want four of the five fields they could
choose to define that which lets you get
a very simple version what we call
consumer driven contracts which lets you
say well if i drop that field do any of
my consumers actually use it
i haven't seen many folks actually do
that most folks are just like it'd be
nice to get everyone to document their
endpoints and if the producer's gonna
tell us what their message is the
consumer will just say that's what i use
right so uh sometimes with this stuff
it's you're better off getting to to
phase one
um with most teams than you are
effectively worrying about wouldn't it
be nice to have a proper cdc over it
all right
so this is what a component looks like
with a message inside it we've done by
ref you can see essentially the message
got a name we have a whole load of
effectively fields
more interestingly perhaps we have these
traits and payload so all we're saying
is that this is the message message has
a payload and we're effectively breaking
out to make it easier to read in the
same component space
we've defined an area called schemas and
we're going to put our
actual message our payload schema into
there traits
traits basically say hey there's
something i want you to effectively
merge in
right and typically quite often a major
use case for this is things like headers
so you can define somewhere in a file um
a set of common headers that you use
without your in your enterprise when
you're sending messages so maybe you
effectively want to define that you use
we'll talk about it later the cloud
event specification you could write up
traits for cloud events and you bring
them in here and you just say merge
those properties into my messages right
that's what trades me
so
going back to what we were saying
earlier about how we define
endpoints
right our async api objects effectively
in our info objects are essentially
describing an endpoint the metadata
about it our channel object effectively
a little bit the information some of the
information there the metadata about um
what's the name of the operation etc
effectively what am i performing
to some extent our metadata about the
end point
um but there's also information really
about the channel right but that's a bit
of a mix between server and the channels
object the server is effectively the
location that you need to go to to talk
to the channel and the channel is
effectively the name of the particular
topic or the routine key whatever your
pla your broker of choice gives you
and the binding information is spread
across servers channels and operation
objects but we can fulfill
the kind of criteria that we established
earlier right um ac kpi 3 i mentioned
that earlier so the nice thing about ac
kpi 3 is they've they're addressing a
few of these non-sequentials ac kpi 2 is
really i i would think it's probably
early adopters or late adopters rather
whereas 18 kpi 3 i would hope would be
the
one to go for early majority and you can
see under operations what we now have is
we say um this is this operation id
refers to an action which in our case is
receive
right but there's another one called
send so i'm actually saying what do i do
not basically what do i expose
and then a description etc on the
binding and channels with their messages
get lifted out so i can define a channel
like for example restaurant on boarded
with this message what is the restaurant
onboarded message look like and i can
define
for a given app am i a sender or a
receiver to that channel
that lets us lift channel definitions
with their messages out into a separate
file which
means we can say okay when i'm
documenting what i've got i want to
document that i've got channels that
live on a broker
right and i have apps that essentially
either send or receive on that channel
so three is a little bit better at
thinking about how we actually structure
pub sub applications generally
okay so um if i'm going to use async api
uh there's a nice thing called product
it's slightly sliced off at the top
async api studio async api studio lets
me write my yaml it's also available in
json json yaml the same thing right um
on the left hand side uh and then
effectively i see on the right hand side
a generated html definition which
provides if you like out of the box
here's some documentation that's
viewable by human beings who don't want
to read yammer
okay
um we also because we nowadays that's
you know path of course have basically a
plug-in for visual code which lets you
essentially do exactly the same thing so
basically we'll recognize async api yaml
and it will generate a preview of the
html that you would generate if you used
that
awesome
um
it has increasing support across a range
of enterprise-friendly tools you know
what backstage is
a few of you backstage comes out of
spotify
it's basically their internal tool for
documenting things that developers want
to share with each other including
documentation of endpoints etc and apis
it'll also do some code generation stuff
for you so it supports async api
effectively alongside open api and
graphql and grpc and everything else
they support but 18 kpis are kind of
first class citizen now in in backstage
so that's if you have a whole load of
these and you want to basically host
them somewhere that's one way of doing
it
there are a whole range of tools
appearing which begin to support acn kpi
so i'm going to pick a couple of them
because i want to give you an impression
of an ecosystem that's emerging around
it and why asian kpi's worth buying into
over just it's a this
thing that's basically no one knows
about apart from me and
so this effectively is called keep it
keeper has an interesting thing cupid
says well given you have effectively got
apps that have send and receive i can
build a graph of those
so i can graph out the nodes which show
you effectively what's talking to what
inside your enterprise right just use a
react to do that
the slight limitation today
um and it's feedback that the 18k player
community has but i'm not sure it'll be
addressed in three
is that we don't really know if your app
receives foo and produces
bar and bars
whether there's a connection between foo
and either bar or bars in other words if
we flow through thinking of basically
some kind of workflow when i get through
i do some action and i and i and i
basically raise bar
or when i flow through i i i take some
kind of action and in the good case i
raise barb and error ray baz there's no
way of understanding whether the
messages that you raise aren't anyway
catch the message you receive as though
there's no tracing right
that's an obstacle for all of us in
event space but uh not that anyone else
has solved it yet but it's still a need
okay talk about how tracing helps later
this is event catalogue this is the come
we're all everyone's a bit excited about
the minute um it's another open source
project
uh async api it's someone said we need
to build catalogues for our events we've
got to visualize them we better document
our apis it was i think
an independent of async api project but
it's support chasing kpi and i think the
ac kpi community is very excited about
it and it's a really nice tool for
effectively um adding your apis in
visualizing basically how they talk to
each other
one we're looking at quite aggressively
it's early days for it but we've been
engaging with the
maintainer who's very proactive and
giving some feedback on
stuff that we need in it but it's
looking very nice and you get these nice
visualizations
which certainly helps
okay
describing contracts
so there are emerging standards for this
section of the contract with an async
api i said async api the box is default
is json schema there are some emerging
standards one of the most interesting
ones is cloud events
cloud events
documents
metadata
not payloads metadata right
and it comes mainly out of vendors
wanting to basically agree a common
standard for metadata for events so if
you are in say azure and listening to
platform events they have basically a
payload but they have a set of headers
right and the idea is across basically
various platforms they wanted to agree
what the header structures would look
like for events that they're raising so
that tooling effectively could listen to
et cetera apart from aws he doesn't want
to be involved because they're the
market leader and you know
open standards um but
uh can events effectively say what
should ahead look like right
cloud events are interested in events
and not commands what is the difference
uh okay
so events are facts and commands are
instructions an event is i am thirsty i
could really do with a cup of tea or
just i am thirsty would be an event
right
a command is please make me a cup of tea
that's the difference
generally with a command we probably
expect to reply
right there are fire and forget commands
but generally we tend to reply so far
and forget the problem would be please
make me a cup of tea and effectively i
know what happened but generally i'm i'm
expecting a cup of tea or someone's
saying yeah i'll get get your cup of tea
right
events are one way in the all the time
they just say something happened i don't
expect a response
right
later on i might receive a signal that
relates to some workflow but i don't
expect a response with an event
events don't know their subscribers for
that reason events are raised into the
ether in case anyone cares about them
but i don't really know who they are
commands always tend to have a known
receiver right i know who the person
that makes tears and i'm going to
address them as opposed to anybody else
because that's how i get my cup of tea
and events have zero to many subscribers
right you may have no subscribers you
may be raising events and no one cares
um uh commands tend to have one one one
subscriber the person i'm talking to
who's going to carry out this operation
i'm asking for right so typically when
you have workflows where effectively
you know there's another step which
someone has to do you too often before
you can complete your step you send them
a command
if it's like i've got some work and when
i'm done with it i'm done and i don't
really care what happens next that's an
event right
so cloud events really only supports the
information on the right hand side so
it's not going to give you information
like what's the reply to header and
things like that right it doesn't want
to do that it just wants to say i care
about events because a lot of its cases
optimizing for platform events coming
from uh cloud providers
yeah okay
so
when we are talking about cloud events
we we say event consists of metadata
payload
the metadata which we care about doesn't
tell us anything about the payload has
required an optional attributes and
cloud events so the required events are
an id
a source who's sending the message a
spec version which version of cloud
events am i going to
does my basically attributes come from
and a type which is the name plus
version so greeting v1 greeting v2 base
says what is my message and which
version message is it all in one
it has a data content type it says when
you look at the payload what what what
is it is it plain text is it binary
right
and a schema and it says if you want to
know what the payload looks like you
should go here and that's where the
payload is defined but it has says
nothing about how that payload is
defined it just says there's a
definition over here and you can put
that in right and there are optional
attributes those two data type of schema
you don't have to have those for cloud
events
all right
subject which qualifies the source that
says what is this about
right
and a time when did i send it right
pretty obvious okay
obviously nothing about data
so cloud events can be basically binary
or structured
um if you thought publish and subscribe
was a bit confusing this is even worse
right so the cloud events basically
binary and structured is nothing to do
with whether you are sending information
in binary or kind of plain text format
what they mean by that is binary says oh
the protocol i'm using
has some idea of metadata of headers for
messages
just use that
structured says ignore all that whether
it has it or not
put it all in the body and have the body
have an envelope and a body
right
it supports a whole set of protocols
more probably appeared since i put this
slide together and they tend to be quite
responsive about adding new ones
okay
binary looks a bit like that so this is
kafka i can't which version kafka starts
to support headers in but effectively
you can see all the ce underscore
properties they are cloud events
properties saying effectively hey here
effectively is my
version my type
my source my idea my time right etcetera
okay
and then this would be that the same
thing in structured
it's clever kafka right but it's saying
effectively actually the first thing i
need to do is define
this
body and this is plain text and the body
is going to effectively say
okay here are all my headers then here
is my actual application data
all right
it is up to you which you prefer
gosh we've had a lot of fights and about
this internally at my place um i think
uh my personal preference is use binary
works available because
the
broker has made available the option for
you to basically separate out
the
metadata information and it may be
possible for you to use that in the
broker to do operations about inspecting
the body so for example with sns i can
create a filter that effectively just
looks in the header and says i'm going
to route things over here or i'm not
going to give you these messages etc so
i would tend to use
the support for effectively explicit
metadata if you can if you can and only
use basically putting in the body uh if
you have to
all right given that i have schemas i
might want to store them somewhere
although i am pointing at confluence
scheme registry it is just to give you
an example of what they do in a picture
i'm not advocating and use this over
others
so generally a
schema registry effectively says i am
just a huge big dictionary where you can
store your schemas and generally your
producer will register one and your
consumer will consume one something like
uh confluence scheme registry actually
lets you
check at runtime whether messages that
are being sent or received conform to
the schema i'm a little bit
i don't know whether that's necessarily
a great idea i would tend to do that
want to do that at design time and not
have you release something that
basically would break somebody else
but you can also use it for that and
they also provide the ability to do some
kind of forwards and backwards
compatibility all right
so
generally one of the big problems in
messaging is versioning in other words i
change my contract and i don't think
about everybody that's involved and
essentially i break people
um
tools like like the confluence scheme
registry tend to give you schema
versioning in other words what they will
do for you is they will tell you when
you upload a new schema whether it is
forwards or backwards compatible with
older with older versions of the message
that's a useful health indicator to you
to say
i might have broken somebody right it's
quite possible you chosen to drop a feel
that nobody is using which case you
haven't broken anybody but you have to
negotiate at that point to determine
whether you've actually broken somebody
it's one reason why i'm not a huge fan
of runtime checks is because actually i
might not have broken anybody
it is if you like
a
slightly less full-fledged version of
consumer-driven contracts
consumer-driven contracts effectively
say the consumer is exactly what they
use and the producer effectively
validates that effectively their schema
matches all of those consumer contracts
what we're doing here is just saying
is when i look at this version of your
schema and i look at the last version of
the schema what can i tell you about the
compatibility of it right if someone was
to consume that message beforehand and
consume all the fields on it with all
those relevant types would they break
based on this new message effectively
and it'll ignore things like i'm adding
fields etcetera effectively knows that
you can tolerate those
but what it will do effectively is say
you would break whereas cdc would say i
will look at exactly what's being
consumed you can drop a field if no
one's consuming it right
but cdc tooling is there's not really
anyone who's producing anything that
useful pact exists basically for http it
also has some support for messaging it
doesn't
to my mind work particularly well
because you're faking out brokers by
using mocks in the middle and it's over
complicated i think for what it needs to
be which is really hey i can effectively
demonstrate by looking you know a simple
set operation whether or not effectively
you should support that but there's poor
support for cdc at the minute the best
thing out there at the minute probably
are scheme registries um this is free
open source right so you can go and grab
confluence skin registry it is um
it is not not tied to kafka you can use
it for other basically um systems it
supports basically avro plain text and
protobuf for the schema definition of
the protocol
observability all right so we mentioned
effectively that where you know one of
the problems particularly messaging was
tracing
understanding basically the flow we also
obviously want to have some
observability of our messages in
production so we can manage them
properly
so one of the things that i would
probably want to do here
is essentially say
use something like open telemetry what
happens to open telemetry is this
operation i'm onboarding a restaurant
and when i onboard a restaurant messages
flow throughout my system and set up the
things that need restaurants would be
what we call a span and within that span
effectively there are child spans that
essentially say i am now inside
restaurant availability which is doing
whatever it does with me right and what
happens is you can serialize the span
information for open telemetry into your
headers so that effectively you pass it
along as kind of a kind of context to
everybody who down the line
typically a span effectively has an
operation name a start finish timestamp
a context and various attributes that
you define right okay the infrastructure
is code uh that's probably the
interesting bit at the end so how are we
using things like ac kpi so one of the
interesting things with acn kpi you can
do once you defined it all and you
published it
is you can parse it and the 18 kpi uh
and its github provides a parser which
will basically parse the the json or
yaml for you essentially and turn it
into an object model
and then effectively you can use the
object model
out of the box as the generator that
works either react or nun templates but
you could use other things
because the generator and the piles are
separate projects once you pass
something that actually lets you say i'm
going to create a use react to create a
template
and i'm going to turn what i've passed
into something else i'm going to produce
a new document right
so this file produces one or more new
files
right
so
here's an example of the react template
doing that essentially we say hey i've
got basically some async api
um what i'm going to do here a bit hard
to recon so i'm going to basically say
look at that basically determine whether
i have any channels so it has published
there are some i'm subscribing so am i
do i have a kafka subscription on any of
my channels if so what i'm going to do
is create a new file called kafka yaml
and effectively i'm going to basically
spit out some configuration information
based on reading the bindings for that
particular
endpoint right don't write the detail
but just understand the principle
okay so what we do with that then
is you well the simple thing you could
do is generate some html documentation
but what we do that is effectively
provision infrastructure
so we take that
take some pollumi uh basically feed that
yama into bulimia and say to bulimia
please go and generate the relevant
infrastructure for us go and create the
kafka topics go and basically do all the
security that we need effectively i'm
going to provision stuff what that saves
us from is
you know something goes wrong in
production uh somebody cleaning up
things these topics aren't needed
anymore deletes half of them turns out
basically you needed one uh well that's
ever happened uh and effectively you
want to recreate them and rather than
having to redeploy all the apps because
the apps basically create their own
infrastructure you effectively have
declarative states so you can
essentially say hey to pollute me please
recreate everything for me because
somebody broke it
um
okay
uh there are lots of other ideas
probably that the work from this model
but that's one that basically we started
to use and i think it's a really
interesting
capability that comes out of putting
stuff into 18 kpis the ability to then
um use uh turn that into basically uh
something that's paused and then
generate new artifacts from it
typically what we do is we we just
generate because we take the original
yaml generate some new yaml because you
can't have enough yam all right and then
our code effectively reads that yaml and
does does stuff with it uh which is just
simpler than getting anything to unsound
18 kpi we just get to understand
the six or seven things we need in order
to provision the infrastructure
all right and you can do scaffolding so
you could do use the same thing to do
code generation so effectively if you
always tend to write your the way a
worker that consumes messages from kafka
in the same way
teams can basically just say you know
what i'm going to define my endpoint in
async api press a button effectively and
i'll get the first version generated and
i just go and write basically the
relevant code right which saves all that
grunt work of doing all that
configuration and getting it right
imagine if you just got a template that
you want to use
all right
and i say it ends a bit abruptly i can't
think of a you know way of letting you
all down gently but um
but there you go all right
that's that thanks very much